es con todos los detalles
hay un lapso de siete horas y treinta y
siete minutos en el registro de llamadas
que tuvo el expresidente de donald trump
durante el 6 de enero cuando sus
simpatizantes se tomaban el capitolio
así se conoció después de que el comité
de la cámara de representantes que
investiga lo que pasó ese día obtuviera
la información de archivos nacionales
desde las 11 y 17 de la mañana hasta las
6 y 54 de la tarde de ese día no hay
registro en las llamadas del ex
presidente tiempo en el que sus
simpatizantes luchaban contra la policía
entraban a la fuerza al capitolio y
buscaban a legisladores y al propio
exvicepresidente mike pence pidiendo su
cabeza sin embargo se sabe que durante
ese tiempo
trump llamó a senadores como mike lee
conversó también con tommy suberví el
senador por alabama y habló también con
el líder de la minoría de la cámara de
representantes el republicano kevin
mccarthy el comité del 6 de enero de la
cámara representantes investiga si tiene
registro completo de las llamadas de
trump el 6 de enero o si el ex
presidente se comunicó hombres ese día a
través de canales clandestinos de
teléfonos de asistentes o incluso de
teléfonos personales desechables según
lo revela el propio jon botón ex asesor
nacional de seguridad del propio ton 8